Hi, I'm immunosuppressed from Lyme, combined with an autoimmune gene.
Even though my Lyme is in remission, I spent my life playing whack-a-bowl with herbs, essential
oils, professional hoiopathics, whole and organic diet, now more restrictive that's caused
me to lose muscle mass for a specific super biofilm manufacturing pathogen.
All procedures for parasite, reduction, now three times a week for flourishing, protozoa,
detoxing, etc.
So, that's a common initial subjective findings of somebody who's been diagnosed with chronic
mold or chronic Lyme disease.
They've just been over there doing a lot of different things.
They've played whack-a-bowl.
I like that terminology the person's used with herbs and supplements and all this kind
of stuff.
So their question is, it's been years, and my financial resources are depleted and CRISPR,
so if you don't know what CRISPR is, that's genetic, engineering, a person's genes, doesn't
seem to be an option at this time, so there's a lot of research going on with CRISPR, a lot
of people think it's extremely dangerous, some people think it could be a miracle medicine
of the future, but that's for another time.
It's been degrading over time, so I haven't felt well in years as it's truly a game of whack-a-bowl
to stay alive.
Do you have any advice regarding repairing my immune system and stopping the dendritic cell
damage or where to turn?
So dendritic cells are immature white blood cells that will change into whatever's needed at
the time, if there is a local infection.
So I would recommend getting on our autoimmune course, honestly, I certainly can't say,
oh, just take this, this is going to be a miracle cure if I said that.
You should probably not listen to me, because there is no such thing, and people sometimes
get mad when they're on calls like this, and they want us to, you know, you're just like
this one magic supplement away from curing all your problems, sometimes people are looking
for that.
I don't take this person as looking for that.
But the truth is, you've got to learn how to handle if you truly do have an autoimmune
disease, which is extremely common with people that have had chronic Lyme or chronic mold
or chronic health conditions, you know, for more than a couple of years, you have to investigate
if you have an autoimmune disease, and then you treat everything's out the window, you
tend to treat everything differently.
So if you're using herbs, you're using essential oils, and even sometimes help meopathics
can stimulate an immune response, and if you stimulate an immune response and you
have antibodies against self tissue, if you have an autoimmune disease, you're going to
kill that which you have antibodies against, maybe you're going to kill your body.
So you're going to have like a Herk's type reaction, but it's not really a Herk's type
reaction.
It is self-destruction, so it's damaged to the tissue that you have antibodies against.
So investigating that would be my concern.
So if you called our office and you did a case review with me, I'd say we need to do some
autoimmune testing.
Even if you had some in the past, autoimmune diseases have three phases to them, so it could
be in a very, very early stage, not even to the latent phase, where it doesn't even show
antibodies to self tissue anymore.
So a person, I can't people come in and say, well, I did antibody testing three years ago
and my condition's gotten worse, then we run antibody tests and they show antibodies
or thyroid antibodies or rheumatoid antibodies or neurological antibodies, and these are very
serious conditions, and you have to treat them completely different.
Once you have antibodies to self tissue, your whole treatment procedure has to change completely.
So you cannot be using any immune stimulants in herbs, vitamins, et cetera, so you have
to be very careful in what to do.
I'd suggest, you know, on the course, you can go to cuttersclinic.com, and from cuttersclinic.com
on the top, you'll see courses, the chronic disease autoimmune course is what I would suggest.
And I'm not just trying to sell stuff, it's 50 bucks to take the course and it's got dozens
of dozens of dozens of videos and education in it.
So we have doctors that are taking the courses, they're very beneficial.